it's ready again welcome back to CBS
mornings where we're talking about a new
film inspired by the true story of a
critical care nurse who helped stop a
serial killer that serial killer Charles
Cullen in 2004 pled guilty to killing 29
hospital patients and the real number
may even be higher he admitted to doing
it by injecting deadly doses of medicine
in their saline drifts and said there
were more victims likely over his
16-year career more than just the 29
that's a huge number he's serving
multiple life sentences uh his fellow
nurse and friend Amy loughran she helped
stop him she worked with police and she
got him to confess this was crucial the
Thriller the movie we were talking about
is the good nurse starring Jessica
Chastain and it's based on Amy's story
and the senior about to see Amy suffers
a heart episode after growing more
suspicious of Cullen and wakes up to
find him by her bedside take a look
where's the nurse uh don't worry your
last pressure looked pretty good your
heart rate's been below 80 for the last
hour
I saw the lapse and your troponin's high
but it's trending down so you're good
you're okay
you're lucky could have been a lot worse
Hey sir are you awake yeah bring me
discharge Farm I don't think that's a
good idea you should stay overnight yeah
we got this I want to leave AMA you sure
I gotta drive her home make sure she's a
doctor thank you
we're good thank you
and the whole movie is like that you
will watch every minute of it and you
will love it we're joined Now by Jessica
Chastain and Amy loughran wow Amy
that's a real scene from your life it is
yes what was it like and Jessica welcome
back you won an Oscar since the last
time we saw you a lot to talk about uh
you do a wonderful job portraying Amy on
camera or on screen it was a huge honor
I get to tell you it was a huge
good to be a playboy that's a good chest
pain like wake me up wake me that part's
a dream obviously but then the the story
itself though I mean it's a nightmare it
is a nightmare what was it like I could
see you getting emotional just as I was
reading the story the summary and then
just looking at that clip what was it
like to delve into all of this
uh well for me of course you know
reliving it it is very triggering it was
20 years ago so I have had a lot of time
to process it however I have only been
able to watch it once it is it's it's
pretty triggering and Eddie Redmayne
does such an incredible incredible job
truly channeling my friend Charlie that
I hear his voice and it's it's my friend
Charlie all over again the detectives
Danny Baldwin and Tim Braun we were with
them last night and they said the same
thing they actually had to sit back a
little bit because he was sounds exactly
like Charles Cullen Jessica I don't know
Amy but you I thought she did such a
wonderful job portraying you and what
you must have been going through I mean
I was watching you Jessica just do the
IV and the way you the way that you were
handling the patients like you you did
seem to me to be a real nurse well we
went to nurse school you and Eddie did
yeah we spent um two weeks it was we
shot this at the end of the pandemic so
we couldn't really go to nursery school
so they made one for us and we learned
it all we learned IVs I started with
like the first day of like the history
of nursing we learned about Florence
Nightingale but yeah no the compressions
I I that's the one thing I asked I said
what is the most what is the thing
Hollywood always gets wrong and I was
told the compressions did she get that
right yeah and in the screening that was
the one that I was like oh my God her
form but do you know what it is you're
supposed to keep your arms straight and
in your head and this is what you think
you sing the tune you go
and that's the rhythm of the
compressions we we all rely on nurses
nurses rely on each other though it's a
very close occupation and Amy was amazed
actually you're hearing you talk about
Charles Cullen the person who murdered
dozens of people you still when you
think about it you say my friend Charles
I don't even know if you realize you're
doing it no that struck me too so I I
didn't really I met the murderer twice
uh the person I knew was truly a
different person and
um he changes and I saw him go from this
wonderful gentle
soft-spoken great teammate
to
this very angry smug
person that I did not know when did you
start to suspect him
so I wish I could say that I suspected
him early on and I didn't I have I still
have a lot of guilt about that that I
didn't see it sooner yeah uh how could
you see it right honestly we're to so
many hospitals but you were the one who
stopped him right yeah I I mean that's
so important Amy acknowledge and
recognize for those who are familiar
with the story
um and those who will watch this
the question we wrestle with is why and
everybody has their own reason in your
gut knowing him as a friend and a
murderer
why do you think he went down this dark
path
he definitely had a very challenging
childhood that doesn't excuse anything
that he did I had a challenging
childhood
um I do believe that he was very flawed
I think he had a lot of mental illness
he he tried to commit suicide even as a
preaching and he started his murderous
Tendencies even before before he became
before he got he was a teenager before
he was a teenager so I believe uh it was
an obsessive-compulsive disorder gone
awry
that's and again that's just my theory
because he you know what he never gave
an answer right even when asked he said
I got away with it there's a very
crucial scene at the end of the movie
Jess where you got him to confess and in
that moment you were so tender to him
and I was wondering did that really
happen because we got to see his Hume it
was hard to see his Humanity but in that
scene I think he was so beautiful about
what to be a slint Hallmark director
does and this incredible stories we
spend so much time focusing on violence
stopping violence right aggression
stopping violence those are all the
stories we're fed in the media in this
true story what it stops the violence
and the cycle of violence is compassion
and love and Amy reminds him that he's a
human being and reminds of of his
Humanity when everyone else starts to
treat him as a monster and that's what
stops it and this is a show that focuses
on the hero and not the violence and the
murderer and it's one of the first times
I've ever seen something do that you
will certainly focus on nurses I have a
very good friend who was in the hospital
recently and and he was saying that the
difference that the nurses make
everybody gives all the glory to the
doctors Amy but what do you say about
nurses and some nurses can't come in and
you can see that they're really on top
and care and others just seem to be
phoning it in what do you say about
anyone who has ever been in the hospital
and especially in critical care you'll
see the Physicians are only there for
about 30 seconds right maybe a couple of
minutes to come in and get report from
the nurse it's the nurses that will save
your life the nurses will save your life
did you change your perception of nurses
oh it's a hard job I mean we made this
film at the end of the pandemic at the
time where everyone's going outside to
clap you know and acknowledge health
care workers but I think sometimes we
have short-term memories yeah and we
need to remember the people who are out
there caring for ourselves and this film
is about someone who was caring for
others and we weren't really caring for
her yeah and I think we need to look at
that and say are we taking care of the
people that are out there putting
everything on the line for us the movie
ends by saying you're still a good nurse
Amy yeah the movie ends because you're
still a good nurse nurse and a hero yes
yes he is thank you so much we
appreciate you the good nurse is out in
Select theaters today and begins
streaming on Netflix next Wednesday so
good and we have more on the good nurse
on today's CBS mornings podcast the
director and screenwriter discusses why
they focused on amylo awkward story and
were drawn to her compassion humanity
and effort to find Justice